simplify the rate of cans of soda
compared to people so this ratio here
says that we have 92 cans of soda for
every 28 people what we want to do is
simplify this and really just putting
this ratio or this fraction in simplest
form so the best way to do that is just
to figure out what is the largest number
or the largest common factor of both 92
and 28 and divide both of these numbers
by that common factor so let's figure
out what it is and to do that let's just
take the prime factorization of 92 and
then we'll do the prime factorization of
28. so 92 is 2 times
2 times 46
which is 2 times
23
and 23 is a prime number so we're done
92 is 2 times 2 times 23 and then if we
did the prime factorization of 28
28 is 2 times
14
which is 2 times
7. so we could rewrite i'll well i'll
leave the cans of so so we can rewrite
the 92 cans of soda as
2 times 2 times
23
cans of soda
cans
of soda
for every
for every
let me write the people for every two
times two times seven
people
now both of these numbers have a two
times two in it or they're both
divisible by four that is their
greatest common factor so let's divide
both the top number and the bottom
number by four
so if you divide the top number by four
or if you divide it by two times two it
will cancel out
right over there and then if you do the
bottom number divided by 4 or 2 times 2
it will cancel out with that 2 times 2
and we are left with 23 cans of soda for
every 7 people or 7 people for every 23
cans of soda and we're done we've
simplified the rate of cans or the ratio
of cans of soda compared to people i
guess they're considering this a rate so
maybe they're saying how
quickly do seven people consume
cans on over some period but you know or
you can do it as a ratio